so cloud you were a soldier first class
right yeah weird really what's weird
about it
nothing just that you were the same rank
huh as who the first guy I ever left
[Music]
Wow your eyes
yes Aerith is an ancient probably the
last one living you know you're not just
any little girl you're a descendent of
the Ancients you're wrong I'm not an
ancient when we're older and you're a
famous soldier if I'm ever trapped or in
trouble promise you'll come and save me
[Music]
I've never been so proud women must be
hounding you day and night I'd really
love to stay and chat but we gotta go so
soon got more pizza in the oven I'll
take another rush lookie here boys
burglars Chifa I'm coming for you
viciously without mercy
till they vomit blood you seek my
approval do you I should warn you tails
you lose
keep it back give it back cooing I'm
sorry honey I wish I didn't have to
Shinra has confirmed the reactor to be
the target of the bomber shinra's
decided they ought to stamp them out the
sky is falling and avalanche is to blame
but I work for Shinra I'm the enemy I
don't care
greetings and welcome avalanche I
presume you mean you're not here to give
president Shinra has come up and I've
also drafted a we have will not be
needed two words
they're going to drop the plate on us
yes
whispers perhaps best described as
arbiters effect no you don't not when
I'm working I promise you will regret
this the sector in which you stand has
been condemned
you're a soldier aren't you which of
course would mean that I own their
suffering you will grow strong isn't
that what you want access the 300 pound
sack of it eh
justice honor freedom vain indulgences
agree more every time the whispers
touched me I lose something a part of
myself
tonight marks a new beginning for Sidra
this could well be the last line of
defense let's go
let us defy destiny together cloud
there's still so much to be done
you